bonjour et merci d'être avec mon direct
sur rt france alors destitution de
jeannine mabunda fin de la cognition
tshisekedi joseph kabila
qu est il en train de se passer en
république démocratique du congo
c'est une inversion force vous savez
nous sommes dans un marché de dupes 1-2
le départ le président sortant avait
choisi son successeur mais en conservant
tous les leviers du pouvoir aller prises
dans la joseph kabila l'ancien président
qui avait comme ça à garder la mainmise
sur toutes les institutions qui ce soit
au niveau national que provincial et les
nouveaux donc félix et qui dit n'avait
pas vraiment les contrôles de n'avait
pas suffisamment des marges de manoeuvre
pour pouvoir avancer sa politique ou
imprimer une vision politique donc
progressivement c'est que s'est passé
hier sept sites
c'est une banque c'est juste une
succession une étape de plus dans cette
stratégie kamnik progressivement en
place le nouveau président pour
récupérer quelques marges de manoeuvre
et il est en train d'errer sur donc on
assiste à une inversion vraiment des
rapports de force à kinshasa oui tu sais
qu'aider qui tente en fait de renverser
la majorité parlementaire donc première
étape avec la destitution de jeannine
mabunda désormais il faut réussir à
dégager une nouvelle majorité au sein de
l'assemblée nationale
est ce que ce sera fait dans quel délai
moi je pense que c'est très possible
c'est très probable que les présidents
félix tshisekedi parvienne à ses fins
donc c'était un test hier faire sauter
un bureau de l'assemblée nationale dans
une assemblée nationale dominée par les
fc s'est largement dominé d'air donc si
félix tshisekedi a réussi ces tests
rien rien et pour tout cas bloquer la
constitution de cette nouvelle majorité
très rapidement je pense parce que le
président voulait nommer un informateur
pour identifier justement la
recomposition politique au sein de
l'assemblée nationale et il était but
est un peu
par la constitution de la république
démocratique du congo qui l'obligent à
contresigner l'ordonnancement de nouveau
l'informateur par les premiers ministres
donc comme il ya déjà c'est signal fort
qui la majorité parlementaire est entré
d'être échangé je pense que la prochaine
étape sera de confirmer cela par une
décision une motion au sein de
l'assemblée nationale pour demander le
départ du premier ministre et cela
permettra au président de la république
facilement alors d'initier le processus
d'un formateur ou même des nommés
directement et un nouveau premier
ministre
alors il ya inquiétude un de la
communauté internationale est ce que on
est au début d'une crise politique de
large ampleur la crise politico nier là
c'est juste une étape depuis son enfance
encore dans la crise politique
on même si aujourd'hui on a vraiment du
mal à lire la stratégie la stratégie de
riposte du front commun pour poly congo
donc la plateforme de joseph kabila
parce que là on est à une énième défaite
politique des cdc règlement politique
il vous souviendra que quelques quelques
jours avant avant cette victoire des
flux qui ce qu'a dit le président est
venu à l'assemblée nationale à l'absence
malgré les refus de la présidente à
l'époque dont gm honda et il est venu
rester voir la prestation de serment des
trois juges constitutionnels avant ça le
président tshisekedi a profité ou a
envoyé le premier ministre al bachir
pour derrière lui prendre des
ordonnances nommant des hauts
fonctionnaires de l'état
le rcc a protesté mais ce mesirow sont
rencontrés en vigueur donc à une
succession des décisions il ya une
succession de défaites 10 front commun
pour le congo sur le terrain politique
on n'a pas vu une riposte à ces assez
avancée du président félix ce qui est
dit dans dans les camps de
des sonnex désormais ex allié joseph
kabila dans le fond cette coalition a
tué sec a dit kabila est ce que ça
rassurait pas un peu voilà là
aujourd'hui on est on se rend compte
finalement que l'édile politique
compenser en tout cas que la communauté
internationale à accompagner pour
assurer une certaine stabilité parce
qu'on sortait d'un régime qui est resté
18 ans au pouvoir et on a reçu les pays
a réussi à faire cette alternance
pacifique au sommet de l'état alors les
gens sont contentés de dire ok ben comme
n'y a pas de sens peut-être c'est une
bonne chose la stabilité sera maintenue
mais on a constaté avec les temps que on
a passé déjà deux ans des statu quo
parce qu' aucune réforme majeure
aucune réforme structurelle n'a été
engagée au pays les deux plateformes qui
qui étaient aux affaires c'est ce qu'on
puisse passer l'état s'est disputée il
ya eu beaucoup de tension tout au long
de ces deux années et pendant ces deux
années aussi l'autre camp les camps des
félix séguin 10 a réussi progressivement
à inverser les rapports de force et à
reprendre la main alors on a on a comme
je disais tout à l'heure encore la
stratégie de riposte de dief si c'est
pour vraiment faire rentrer les pays
dans une autre crise politique où les
deux piliers même militaire on a du mal
encore aujourd'hui à définir ce qui peut
se passer
merci à beaucoup entre messieurs qui
m'en voulais d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique au groupe
d'étude sur le congo merci